yeah though you at the beginning of
parasite men shows up with the scholars
stone ki-woo is immediately attracted to
the stone he stares at it intently the
next cut is a break and continuity a
jump in time the stone has already been
lifted out of the box and ki-woo is
looking in a totally different direction
but this jump is barely noticeable the
dialogue from this shot starts under the
previous shot making the jump in time
almost imperceptible the transition from
a closer shot to a wide shot also keeps
us from being a jump cut but the subtle
passing of time is an accidental we
enter into ki-woo subjective perspective
in this moment we're experiencing his
attraction to the rock and it's almost
as if he and we the audience lose track
of time and snap back to reality
a moment later realising time has passed
there are many examples of this kind of
subtle and precise editing and parasite
that we could examine but parasite
provides us with a great opportunity not
just to examine and break down some
examples of effective editing but to ask
ourselves what editing is and who really
does editing in a film this video is
sponsored by Mubi check out their
curated collection of streaming cinema
and movie comm slash Thomas flight most
likely the majority of films and TV
shows you watch are shot with a process
called coverage when shooting a scene a
director and cinematographer will
usually shoot the scene from a variety
of angles they'll shoot some wide shots
close-ups medium shots and
over-the-shoulder shots then it will be
the job of the editor to stitch together
the scene from all these takes the
director hopefully has an idea going
into the scene of how it will progress
visually but with coverage you have an
option in the Edit of changing the
visual structure of the scene we know
from interviews with bong joon-ho that
he did not shoot coverage for Paris
except where it was absolutely necessary
this means for a scene like this where
the entire scene plays out from a single
angle this was probably the only angles
I shot this scene from they didn't shoot
any other angles just in case they
wanted to change how the scene
progressed in the Edit so in this case
instead of creating the visual
progression of the scene the editors job
is just to choose the best take and time
the transition into an out of the shop
for bong joon-ho one of the reasons he
can avoid shooting coverage is that he's
often incorporating or planning how the
film will be edited together in the
script and in his storyboards let's look
at this scene as the conversation shifts
to the idea of counting the parks the
visual composition of the scene changes
he owned her own taxi in Toronto and we
have this shot da-da-da-da-da-da net1
12 a bonus una ventana it's a transition
from here to here and from using this
angle of men to this angle of men was
planned for this moment in bong joon-ho
storyboards and cinematographer Kyung
Pahang just shot the scene the way it
was storyboarded an editor Jim o yang
just followed bong storyboards and
stitched the two shots together do we
attribute the effectiveness of the end
result to editing cinematography or
directing ultimately no matter which
person made the creative decision or if
it was made in pre-production
post-production or production we can
attribute the effectiveness of the
transition to editing when we use the
word editing or often incorporating two
things into that definition first we're
referring to the activities of the
actual editor and the creative decisions
they make but we're also referring to
the concept of an edit in film language
this is sometimes called montage I'm not
talking about montage sequences like the
one you see later in parasite a montage
sequence uses a faster series of shots
that usually convinces time-space and
information
when I say montage here I'm referring
specifically to the creation of meaning
through the visual juxtaposition of two
shots by itself this is just a shot of a
stone and by itself this is just a shot
of ki-woo but edited together they
create a moment where he whoo looks at a
stone that's montage and montage is the
fundamental building block used by
editors to create meaning but montage
and editing can happen long before a
film is even shot towards the end of
parasite there is a lot of inner cutting
between different locations and
characters a lot of action is happening
all at once but this is carefully
managed in a way that is seamless we can
attribute this seamlessness and pacing
to editing but it isn't just the editor
who's responsible for how these scenes
flow together and our inner cut for
example here's a cut from the kitchen to
the basement is aided by Cheung silks
glance towards the stairs the
performance and the Edit have to work
together to create that smooth
transition it's the work of the editor
to time the cut with look but for the
editor to do that the look has to exist
in the performance and in this case it
originates in the script but I'm not
trying to diminish the work of parasites
editor Jimbo yang or give all the credit
to bong joon-ho by making strong and
effective creative editing decisions
early on director bong is simply giving
his editor more time and space to work
on everything else some scenes are still
shot with coverage and it's up to Jim mo
yang to work out the timing of the cuts
in those scenes in this scene
it appears coverage was shot it looks
like the entire scene was probably
filmed from these four angles ya see but
it was horrible good way they thought I
secure
here the editor cuts to this shot
crossing the line of action instead of
cutting back to this angle which stays
on the line of action this choice
emphasizes the idea that mr. Kim is
someone who will cross the line the
material to be able to make this choice
crossing the line and creating meaning
through montage had to be provided by
the cinematographer and it was probably
planned for by bomb
but if coverage was shot the editor
still needs to decide when is the right
moment in that scene to cut to that new
angle in this scene we see the
housekeeper inside over video and also
on the outside in the rain an important
decision for the scene is when to show
her on the outside in the film we don't
see her outside until right before mrs.
Kim takes some pity on her and lets her
in the shot mirrors some shots of the
Kim's from earlier and so I think it
makes sense to show her outside for the
first time when mrs. Kim relates to her
and has sympathy on her but this shot
could have come at the beginning of the
scene or in the middle and it's up to
the editor to make that decision but
even with the constraints of no coverage
shooting they're still a lot an editor
can do as VFX become cheaper better and
more accessible they're increasingly
used by editors in subtle ways to
improve timing and performance the lock
down shots in a moment like this it's
easy to composite two shots together to
perfect the timing of actions here's
another example if I wanted in the shop
for the housekeeper and the dog to come
in a little earlier that would be a very
easy adjustment to make but it goes
deeper than that in an interview with
the art of the cut jumo yang revealed
that shot stitching is used in the film
even during pans on longer unbroken
takes in the same way the editor of 1917
can combine multiple takes to create the
illusion of one longer take editors like
Jim o yang can use the same techniques
to combine multiple takes - perfect
timing or combine two different
performances and if they're not spending
most of their time constructing scenes
from coverage the editor will have more
time to spend perfecting every little
detail the role of editing is massive
and far-reaching in film but the
building blocks of good editing often
start with the script and cinematography
a great editor will be able to create
magic from scenes shot with coverage
coverage itself isn't bad but often when
a director like bong joon-ho is planning
the cinematography performance and
editing and how they'll work together
from the beginning of the process it can
lead to a quality of work difficult to
achieve otherwise in the same way the
editor of a film is often referred to as
the last screenwriter the screenwriter
is in a sense the first editor even if
they're never communicating directly in
reality the editor is working in
collaboration on the Edit with many
other members of the film crew
understanding editing will make you a
better screen writer or cinematographer
an understanding screenwriting and
cinematography will make you a better
editor this video is sponsored by Moby
parasite was a film that I think made a
lot of people realize that the world of
international film has a lot to offer if
you want to have more access and find
interesting indie films arthouse films
or international cinema check out movie
movie has 30 films at a time and they
add a new one every day it's a great
place to find new stuff and you can try
it for free for 30 days when you go to
movie.com / thomas flight that's m ubi
dot-com / thomas flight
thanks so much for watching if you want
to see some additional commentary on
parasite that just didn't fit into one
of these essays you can watch this
month's bonus video on my patreon by
becoming a patron for five dollars a
month at patreon.com slash Thomas flight